so while the road to Civil War is really
kind of this crescendo really kind of
this build-up to the civil war storyline
proper the civil war storyline itself
really kind of hits the ground running
as we begin our discussion on the civil
war you will see that we will basically
go from zero to sixty that we will start
the story and from the time we start to
the time we end it'll basically be
non-stop there really won't be very many
slow moments a lot of the slow moments
that exists exists outside of the Civil
War storyline proper they exist within
the times and the times is really kind
of where you get the background story of
what's going on it really kind of fills
in a few things now for the most part
we're not really going to be discussing
the tie-ins properly we're really going
to kind of be skimming over the ones
that aren't really essential to
progressing the civil war story and what
I would encourage you all to do is to
really kind of follow along with the
tie-ins if you can get your hands on
them is to really kind of read about the
tie-ins and at the very least really
kind of try to give a summary of them so
you can follow along with the full Civil
War storyline now what we see with a
story is that the new warriors have
really kind of come into contact with
some super villains they are trying to
catch them by surprise as they invade
their home and the suburb of Stamford
Connecticut
but what we see is that they're really
kind of caught out of their league these
guys are really a lot more powerful than
they had initially expected and in fact
one of the super villains a villain
named nitro really kind of self
detonates and blows up a huge portion of
Stanford the initial casualties are
expected to be around 600 but as we'll
see with us the progression of the civil
war storyline the actual casualties end
up being well over a thousand now
initially around sixty to seventy or
maybe even as many as a hundred people
who were killed or composed of children
and so from here we really kind of see
this public backlash now after the
events of nitro destroying a huge
portion of Stanford we switched to the
Office of national emergency alongside
the Avengers and the x-men who are
really kind of assisting in cleanup and
they're really kind of trying to find
survivors or at the very least try to
find some bodies now from there this is
when we really kind of get into the
ramifications of the event and we really
kind of see things begin to move
at a very fast clip we get a couple
panels of she-hulk being interviewed on
CNN and the way that she takes this is
really kind of interesting
initially she's really kind of against
the idea of just arbitrarily rounding up
superhero she really kind of feels as
preposterous but the idea of at the very
least kind of regulating them of
requiring them to register themselves
and it really kind of be government
regulated isn't necessarily something
that she is against now one of the more
interesting aspects is when we switch to
the funeral for the many people who had
been killed in the events of Stamford
Connecticut and of course we see one of
the victims mother really kind of
lashing out at Tony Stark and really
kind of screaming at Tony Stark and and
yelling at him that it's his fault that
everything that had happened to this
point was really kind of on their
shoulders and this is when we see the
anger and the irritation of humanity on
behalf of superheroes really kind of
coming out because up until this point
when we saw events unfolding when we saw
various conflicts taking place that
resulted in the destruction of cities or
things like that it was really kind of
superhero showing up they were fighting
the fight they were destroying the
villain and there was really no
consideration for the amount of damage
that was caused there was really no
consideration for the possible
casualties that had been caused there
was really kind of this argument that
the ends justify the means now not all
of the superheroes really kind of agreed
with this mindset especially when it
came to people like Captain America but
the fact that there was no real
ramification because of the fact that
the government had never really stepped
in and said okay enough is enough people
began to really kind of develop this
perception and they really kind of began
to believe that there's really no one
holding these superheroes accountable
and so at this point we really kind of
see the tide begin to change we're in
the road to Civil War storyline we had
talked about the events and really kind
of the congressional meetings between
Congress and Tony Stark and spider-man
and the 50-50 split between those who
were supportive of superhuman
Registration and those who were against
it we see the tide turn to where it's a
far more lure for a much larger group of
people who are in support of superhuman
Registration than those who were against
it now from here we see you know I guess
you can kind of consider the first
casualty of the the backlash of the
anger of humanity when we see that
Johnny Storm
attacked in a nightclub and he is beaten
unconscious and actually put into a coma
now at this point we really kind of
jumped to a major meeting that is taking
place and this is really this is really
kind of important because this is when
we really kind of see battle formations
for me we really kind of see the lines
being drawn in the sand we see the
Avengers the Fantastic Four spider-man
among other superheroes meeting at the
Baxter building to really kind of
discuss whether or not registration is
something they can go through we see of
course daredevil says that things are
never going to be the same and we see
that people are either avidly against it
or they're avidly in support of it there
really is no middle ground here there
really isn't anyone who's kind of like
well let's just wait and see what
happens we really kind of see people
drawing lines in the sand and we
actually see some individuals who had
previously been friends really kind of
splitting up and going separate ways and
this I think is really kind of one of
the more pivotal points and really kind
of one of the reasons why this series
was called the Civil War now from this
point we jump to Captain America and
Captain America is really kind of an
issued an ultimatum by shield as it's
being led by Maria Hill and Maria Hill
really kind of tells him the direction
that things are going and is that you
guys are going to have to be registered
you're going to have to sign up and
really kind of tell the government who
you are and you're going to be regulated
it can either be easy or it can be
difficult of course Captain America who
is always on the side of freedom elect
for the difficult path he overpowers all
of the shield agents including Maria
Hill and then goes underground now this
is extremely important when Captain
America goes underground and the reason
why is because as we transition will see
that the general public is in front of
the White House and they're avidly in
support of registration and we see that
Iron Man is meeting with the president
along with several other political and
military officials and Ironman goes as
far as to say that the problem here is
that with Captain America being
underground people who are against
registration now have a figurehead they
have someone they can rally around and
so now they will not be as diverse and
separated and as easy to conquer more or
less as they would have previously been
because not only do they have a
figurehead they have the figurehead they
have the one God that would be the best
person to use to rally anyone to a
particular cause in the form of Captain
America and from this point moving
forward in the comics what we'll see is
basically kind of a rush we'll see a
race taking place between Captain
America and Iron Man where each one is
attempting to divvy up superheroes
initially they start with the most
popular person the most popular people
ant-man and so on and so forth and then
they kind of work their way down the
line and they begin to pretty much go
for whoever they can get we also see
them and listen the aid of individuals
who are a little less savory in addition
to individuals who really kind of are in
the middle of the road and really aren't
sure which direction they want to take
and will really kind of see that come to
fruition with the x-men now as far as
the tie-ins are concerned I would say
probably one of the most important
tie-ins between civil war issue number
one and civil war issue number two is
the amazing spider-man issue number 532
and the reason why is because as we saw
with the road to Civil War Ironman had
enlisted the aid of Peter Parker he had
told Peter Parker that he needs him
really more than anybody else to be on
his side and the reason why is because
spider-man is a very well recognized
figure in the superhero community and
for the most part if spider-man will go
along with it people will lend a little
more credence to it than they normally
would have just because of the fact that
he is really kind of always fighting on
the side of good and he is always trying
to help people as best he can even if
it's at the risk of his own personal
detriment and as we progress through
this comic we will ultimately see at the
end that spider-man will stand in front
of the press and reveal himself to be
Peter Parker with that being said I'm
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end I really hope you guys enjoyed it
if you guys have any suggestions for the
future videos or if you would like me to
go more in depth we go into the tie-ins
and please let me know and I will catch
you guys later peace
you